[Music]
i
can't think of a headline more likely to
trigger
not just me but every blooming woman in
britain
scientists blame working mums for uk's
child obesity epidemic
i'm sorry good grief where to start
with the news that a kid is more likely
to be overweight if the mother's
employed
repeat after me all mothers
are working mothers whether they work
inside the home
or outside the home meanwhile it made
no difference to a child's weight
whether her whether or not
their father worked which tells us
everything we need to know
it's because women still are in the main
primary caregivers and responsible
for goshwell pretty much everything
which is why kfc's
family mega bucket deal was famously
marketed
as mum's night off it's mothers not
fathers who are judged if junior eats
junk food
in front of the telly the fact that
buffon's mum shame for this
tells us so much more about fathers than
it does about mothers and
also tells us it's long overdue for dads
to step up to the dinner plate and pull
their weight
yeah pretty much agree with everything
you said uh all mothers are definitely
working mothers
uh the reason that children are probably
getting larger is
a combination of factors they're not
eating as healthy as they probably did
there's too much fast food which is
laden with all sorts of salt and
all sorts of things they should meeting
but it also actually comes back to both
central and local government which is
there aren't enough schools with playing
fields a lot of the playing fields have
been sold off
exercise doesn't take place in school uh
possibly not given enough
priorities it should be so i agree to
all of the above more should be done
that's why we're really it's nothing to
do with working with you
working dad yeah that you haven't pulled
your weight in
at home as much as you could have done
well mine was a different situation
because of course when i divorced the
children stayed with me
so it's a slightly different situation
so i didn't have a choice if i hadn't
fed them
we all wouldn't be here so it's
different okay well that's interesting
to hear but
for the i think for the most part women
are primary
can we just have a look at some figures
so the viewer has a sense of what had
the
imbalance of in the housework load
between men and women and you see from
these screens that on cooking child care
laundry and housework women do do unlike
you nick
about more than twice and these these
figures and i don't
i will yield after this no the classic
stereotype
stereotypical home is yeah you're right
dad goes off he on a friday night he
goes to the pub with his mates or
whatever and poor old mum probably is
doing a shift as well
she comes back and she looks after
because mine was an exceptional set of
circumstances
so i am in a position where i have a
child a two-year-old and therefore
currently in the position where i could
be or could not be a caregiver depending
on how the arrangement is and currently
our arrangement
and i think partly because the problem
is i am a
working when i work i work on a fees
basis not on a p-a-y-e basis so i don't
get
uh paternity leave and so part of the
arrangement we made was a
purely pragmatic arrangement based upon
how we can both achieve what we want in
the long term
so it ended up being that i take the
primary
primary division of financial labor even
though she also works but then i pay for
the child care now the problem with that
setup
is of course people that can't afford to
do that
can't afford to do that and so then the
mother ends up becoming the primary
caregiver and that's that's basically
not fair
on either side i wish i had paternity
leave i wish the law
allowed me to spend more time with my
child and paid me to do it
and currently it doesn't and if i did do
that we wouldn't be able to pay the rent
michelle you're a modern young woman
when you
share a house with your partner which i
assume you will
at some point are you going to make sure
that he does 50
because all the surveys show that even
if both partners are working the woman
still does more
my boyfriend would absolutely
um do what we what you need to do so i
even i like a cup of tea in bed when i
wake up not that you need to
have this insight into my life me and my
boyfriend absolutely take it in turns
to make it one day he'll do it the next
day i'll do it there is no way i know
but that's a little loving gesture
michelle i'm talking about who people
are
i was about how long have you been going
out
um long enough um how many weeks
yeah precisely honestly give it a couple
of months left it's never going to
happen
we've got to move it away from
michelle's love life or sexuality it's
serious
i wouldn't be in a relationship where
the man expected me to do the lion's
share of the cooking
you say
that can testify to this i wouldn't have
it i would love it
can i can i bring it down to a less
glamorous level than having
been waited on with the lovely team beds
i remember those days um
i love this cartoon because it i just
recognize it and i suspect other women
will recognize it too this is the mental
load
a feminist comic by emma she says i
start by picking up something to put it
away
but on the way i come across a dirty
towel that i go to put in the laundry
basket
which i find full so i go to the washing
machine and i see the vegetables that
need to be put in the fridge and as i'm
putting away the vegetables i realize
that i need to add mustard to the
shopping list
and so on and so forth in the end i've
cleared away my table after two long
hours
only to find it covered in stuff again
later that evening
if i ask my partner to clear the table
he'll just clear the table the towel
will stay on the floor the vegetables
will rot on the kitchen counter
and we won't have any more mustard for
dinner i
actually think that that is so
reflective of things you can't even
imagine
until you are in a domestic situation
where you're doing like three loads of
washing every night and you're doing
your online shopping while you get
dinner ready while you're
arranging someone's house yeah you're a
mother as well i'm a mother i have a
seven-year-old daughter
and i mentor young women and when i
mentor them one of the things i
always tell them is choose your partner
so carefully
choose your partner so carefully because
before i had a child i couldn't have
imagined did you choose wrong
oh i made i made a phenomenally wise
choice for which i take no credit for
which i take no credit but
i wish somebody had told me to do it
deliberately that when you choose your
partner it needs to be somebody
who is not just ideologically committed
to being on board but
it feels equally invested that you don't
have to delegate to that person that
they will take responsibility but i also
think this is structural it's not just
about individual choices because
this is why the pay gap matters men are
getting paid more it means that men
don't have the option
of being the one that's what i was
hinting who stays there then they
are under pressure to be the one to work
because they earn more it makes economic
sense i mean
i'm married to an artist who paints on
canvas and she ain't you know she ain't
selling paintings every day i can tell
you that so there's a problem right
there
even though your situation is a bit
specific because you're self-employed as
well a lot of couples even though they
have
that idea that they want to share find
themselves pressurized by the way that
their incomes
are structured that the man ends up
being the one that goes to work the
woman is the one who is at home more and
then they get stuck in those roles
and that when the man comes home from
work he's not being in tune with all of
the tasks that need doing and it just
perpetuates them no matter how good your
intentions are it can be quite hard to
push back against
everything society is putting on you to
the mother's on the panel can you can
you have it all i mean is that has that
now been debunked
in your view uh
i think you can but you do need as i
said earlier
you know you need to have a fairer
division of household labor
if a woman's going to be able to work
and have children and have a life
that isn't in just domestic drudgery
she needs support at home and in your
case it's
it's paid it's financial but can we go
back to my topic
which is why are we shaming mothers and
blaming them for obesity when it's
obviously a
very complex i think everybody agrees
it's wrong though the reason that we've
moved away is i i mean i think that's
shame
i like the way you read the headline
though i was wondering if you could do
that if you could bring in any clips or
cuttings in that way i'd be
you know much better for disposal but no
i don't think there's any uh
it's an absurd suggestion but i think we
do still have these internalized ideas i
mean i still hear people at the school
gate when a dad is the one who drops the
child of every day game isn't he
wonderful
really isn't he you know you should have
seen me
yeah you must have been laughing that
well i don't know
right well it's described as one of the
toughest
challenges on earth and i'm not talking
about working with this lot every week
but we've got more people climbing mount
everest or going into space
then successfully rowing across the
atlantic solar
weeks at sea by yourself 40-foot waves
limited food supplies and only sleeping
for two
hours at a time would challenge even the
most committed sportsmen
but lee spencer was determined not to
let
any of that or the fact that he's had
one of his legs amputated five years ago
stop him
the former royal marine not only
succeeded in rowing himself
from mainland europe to south america he
smashed the record for doing so
by 36 days and here's what he had to say
when he reached the finishing line after
61 days at sea
the thing that's that kept me going has
been exactly that
proving that no one should be defined by
disability
that no one should be defined by
something that they're not good at
records are there to be broken
um i'm so glad i got it and thank you so
much
it's it's actually beginning to sink in
though
lee spencer i love you and you are our
record breaker
of the week and while undoubtedly his
rowing skills are without question
perhaps his
knowledge of broadcasting not quite the
same because let's be honest about it if
you've done it for that amount of time
you've been at sea you
probably fancy a drop of beer what he
didn't realize was that the cameras were
rolling during all his broadcast
interviews
[Music]
so each gap in the interviews having
been on the drink he decided to have a
drink i don't blame him
a huge amount of respect for him and he
shows it's not what happens to you but
it's how you respond to it
which matters right that is it for this
week
but if you want to join in the debate
just search for the pledge
on facebook or twitter but be nice
see you next time